foreign
foreign
yale has a proud tradition of
involvement in
and ties to military service
many of us have walked by the statue of
nathan hale
who sacrificed his life for his country
in the revolutionary war
we have read the cenotaph on the
quadrangle that honors the hundreds of
yale students and alumni who died
in world war one through our shared
history
the yale community is connected to
thousands of yellies who served in the
first and second world wars
korea and vietnam
this connection extends to the faculty
students
staff and alumni who serve today
the spirit of service and sacrifice that
link our military personnel
is a hallmark of yale's mission
our university is characterized by a
deep commitment
to the common good and to the security
and prosperity of generations to come
in these turbulent times i am more
grateful than
ever for all those who work to
strengthen the fabric of our university
of our country and of communities around
the globe
i appreciate deeply our faculty staff
and alumni
who are veterans yale is committed to
supporting our veterans
through programs like the yale veterans
network
a campus group of students faculty and
staff
and the yale veterans association an
alumni organization
and yale is proud of its students who
currently serve
and the reserved officers training corps
on campus
the coven 19 pandemic has shown us how
necessary it is that two great
institutions of american society
its universities and its professional
armed services
are here to educate future leaders in
how to handle the trials
and uncertainties in life
as we mark veterans day it is vitally
important
for us to remember the human toll of war
individuals have made and continue to
make extraordinary sacrifices in service
to this country
our veterans have my deepest gratitude
and respect
today and every day we thank them
for their service
so
so
so
so
to begin i'd like to thank president
salovey and secretary goff cruz for
leading the university and honoring
veterans each year
i also want to thank dean soti patricia
way and jack beecher
who each play a role in ensuring the
success of student veterans
in 2011 i was looking for some
excitement and a way to pay for college
convinced i knew what i was doing i
enlisted in the marine corps
after working on unmanned aircraft and
serving as a marine security guard
at embassies and consulates i decided to
earn a degree in an officer's commission
through the marine corps enlisted to
officer program
in 2017 after being accepted to yale's
eli whitney students program
i moved to connecticut to begin my
assignment as a full-time undergraduate
after settling in i couldn't wait to
meet my neighbors i was especially
curious about marion
who lives three doors down marianne is
92 years old
and she spends most of her days pulling
weeds and trimming flowers in the garden
before covet 19 she went to the gym
three times a week
when her gym decided to close in march
she was outraged and told me that she
just didn't know how she would stay in
shape
marianne and i don't seem to have much
in common she was born
in 1928 almost 90 years before all
military jobs opened to women
she attended new haven's hill house high
school where she learned how to cook and
sew
despite the many differences in decades
between marian and me
we do have one thing in common her
husband george was a marine
also in new havener george was born in
1923
and was commercial high school's star
basketball player when marion showed me
his team picture
she wanted me to know that despite being
the shortest on the team
he was their best player like many in
his generation
he enlisted soon after graduating in
1941.
george would go on to fight two of the
war's most historic battles
at iwo jima where marines and a navy
corpsman raised the [ __ ] on mount
suribachi
and in okinawa the bloodiest battle of
the pacific war
marian has told me that george never
talked to her about the war
but that he was a marine through and
through that he loved his country
his family and that he was proud to have
served he was outgoing
and in marion's words he had a lot of
parties she told me that if he were
alive today
he would have had some great stories to
tell me but that he never exaggerated
to be fair i don't think there'd be much
room for embellishment
after returning from the war he met
marion at franklin street's falcon dance
hall
on valentine's day 1946 they were
married the next year
settled into civilian life and
eventually moved to the street we live
on today
when george was in his 50s he enrolled
at the university of new haven
and earned a degree in business marianne
was very proud when she told me
that this degree usually took four years
but that george did it in two
i laughed when she said this thinking
about about zach metcalf marine and
timothy dwight
class of 2018 who also did it in two
george and marion were married for 70
years
what i've learned from marion besides
how great life can be at 92
is that the pride that comes with
service is not only felt by us
it's also felt by our families this is
part of the reason we celebrate
veterans day is for those who have
served and it's for marion for people
like my own parents
and for many of you listening today who
admire the service and sacrifice of
someone close to you
i'm reminded of this each time marion
asked me about my experiences in the
marine corps
or invites me inside to show me pictures
of george i'm also reminded of this
when the naval rotc midshipmen and i
gather on the steps of sterling memorial
library
and campus visitors stopped to tell us
about their son or daughter who was
serving
or their own stories from the navy or
the marine corps
i think this message is especially
fitting this year and although we can't
gather together to celebrate
students faculty staff and alumni we're
joined virtually
by more friends and family than probably
ever before
so to all veterans past present and
future thank you for your service and
your sacrifice and happy veterans day
wow
bye
our loving and merciful god of many
names
and all generations we are thankful
beyond measure
for the courage commitment and
sacrifices of our veterans
who have served bravely and selflessly
in the united states
armed forces on land sea or sky
the legacy of their service to our
country and to
our world is one that must never be
forgotten
we remember with deep respect and
unending gratitude
those who have lost their lives in this
service
we are forever in their debt and we
honor their families
whose loss can never really be made
whole
gracious god we also ask for continued
healing
for all those who struggle with the
visible
and invisible scars of war
we ask special regard for those who have
served
but who have not been found and returned
home
and for those who have returned but who
have yet to find themselves
at home we hold close in our hearts
those who are currently deployed and ask
that your gentle hand
watch over them and guide them safely
back
to their loved ones may we never forget
all that our many veterans have done to
protect freedom
in human rights as we work to realize
the kind of world
you our loving god intends for us
may we continue to seek peace peace born
from wisdom and understanding
nurtured with compassion and mercy
strengthened by courage and commitment
for this we say amen
you